I'm going to play a video for you today
it uh it is a video of a right-wing
meteorologist going completely mental on
Tucker Carlson I thought I was on
hallucinogens I I thought maybe someone
slipped acid into my cappuccino or a
flat white I've been going more in the
direction of the flat white lately
something about that foam but that's
really for a different day I thought I
was on something when I saw this video
because the video doesn't make any sense
a Fox News propaganda Tucker Carlson who
does entertainment remember when if when
when the rubber hits the road
and Tucker gets sued uh lawyers go oh
this is not news this is entertainment
okay he did a segment an entertainment
segment I guess with a meteorologist
named Joe bastardi and that's that's
really his name I'm not I know people
will write in and say David that's
that's rude you're being rude by calling
him bastard no no his name's Joe
bastardi this video is so unbelievably
unhinged but it's a great representation
of how the right to a great degree
I was going to say analyzes but there's
really no analysis here deals with
topics they don't like the right gets
angry that for example people now
believe in climate change and climate
science and bastardi starts rattling off
right wing talking points interspersed
with the word climate change he throws
the word vaccine and covet in there as
well I challenge you to figure out what
the hell this guy is talking about okay
let's get into it well I don't know I've
been giving this a lot of thought today
because I had to drive from uh oh guys
he's been thinking that can't be good
Iowa City all the way to Pittsburgh and
when I went by South Bend oddly enough
it hit me there are three possibilities
here in my opinion just looking at this
okay first is they've all got climate
vaccines we don't know about them but
unlike the covet vaccine they actually
work so whatever they do they're immune
from it so that's a possibility that's a
long time the second
talker is that if bad weather stops air
travel
it stops car travel if you can cause
more bad weather right
then guess what even Tucker is having
trouble following this or pretending to
because that's really all he does at the
end of the day everybody can't drive for
instance next week and the week after
watch how much bad weather comes into
the United States it's going to be the
coldest snowiest period around the
Christmas time since 2000 so now I think
what he's doing right now is it's going
to snow in December so climate change
couldn't possibly be real I I think that
that's what this part of the diatribe is
we're going to see planes and trades and
all these other things shut down so if
you just dump all the CO2 in the
atmosphere and your assumption is hey
CO2 causes bad weather if I can cause
more bad weather then guess what if
you're watching Tucker isn't Frozen he
just looks really confused he's in like
a confused trance people won't be able
to fly will have less CO2 emissions or
or the third possibility exactly what
you said it's a phony climate War it's
fraudulent you could tell back when we
talked back in in July we were talking
about it's going to get cold early this
year across the United States that has
nothing to do with CO2 what it has to do
is the natural cycles of the weather and
what's happened is these people have
taken advantage of people who fall prey
to this and this is what they're doing
there's no logic or reason for it except
they are trying to establish a caste
system that destroys the greatest
experiment and caste system freedom and
individuality which is this country
right here in the United States of
course I mean if you really believe that
carbon was a pollutant you would be
planting Pine and Spruce and Hemlock and
Evergreens across the country but
they're cutting them down to make way
for highways dollar stores that's a
completely unrelated issue and chakra
now pretending to be a a tree-saving
environmentalist is really the cherry on
top that rant that's scrambled mess of
what I believe qualifies as English
language words that's what's going on in
the heads of many of these right Wingers
when you know when when our
correspondent Luke Beasley uh the bee's
knees or whoever they go to the Trump
rallies and they talk to these trumpists
and it's just stuff is coming out you
hear noise coming out of the mouth but
it doesn't really make any sense
this is what's going on in their brain
this is what's going on in their brain
it's just saying climate change every
few seconds while throwing in other
right-wing talking points and this is
that this guy is an outspoken climate
denier he's written books about it uh
the scientific consensus is completely
at odds with everything that he says he
said the world is warmer uh it was
warmer in the 30s than today uh as as
measured how and in what context and
what does that really matter at the end
of the day he says that human
contributions to carbon dioxide are so
small that they couldn't possibly have
any effect science does not agree with
that
um it's a complete and total mess and so
this is sort of like the blind leading
the blind it's the perfect audience the
Fox News audience but these folks are
dangerous because next thing you know
you'll go on the conservative subreddit
and people are repeating the this guy's
exact talking points so this stuff
spreads like a virus they don't seem to
be inoculated against the disinformation
and here we are left to pick up the
pieces and try to figure out how we can
make some progress on dealing with this
issue sad sad stuff very very sad stuff
make sure if you have an Amazon Prime
account that you have subscribed to
Twitch Prime it's free if you have
Amazon Prime and when you subscribe to
Twitch Prime at twitch.tv davidpakman
you basically send us a few dollars that
would otherwise go to Jeff Bezos that
sounds pretty damn good given that it
costs you nothing check it out we're
going to take a quick break and be right
back
you know how tough it can be to navigate
the online news constantly being thrown
at us and that's why I love our sponsor
ground news which is an app and website
that allows you to easily compare how
any individual story is being covered by
different sources every story comes with
a bias bar showing the distribution of
reporting from Left Right and center you
can flip through the headlines to see
how a word or a detail completely
changes the interpretation of a story
you can even see each news Outlet's
parent Corporation so I can distinguish
between independent and corporate owned
sources right now I'm looking at a story
about Iran helping Russia build drones
for Ukraine and I can see it was covered
by 35 sources 17 are government owned
like RT and Ukrainian media
interestingly it looks like the majority
of the coverage is coming from the
center and the right making it a
potential blind spot for the left go to
ground dot News slash Pacman try it for
free or subscribe to get unlimited
access to all of their news analysis
tools the link is down below